deux rondes c'est squeeze et aujourd'hui
il y a cinq mille lots à gagner
les zorros un peu dur à faire ouais j'ai
gagné deux embryons alors tu peux lâcher
mais je te plaît désolé mais merci non
plus sérieusement si je peux vous faire
gagner aujourd'hui 5000 lobont se sont
pas des très gros lot 1 c'est pas dégeu
ou quoi c'est grâce à catania qui m'a
contacté pour que je puisse faire ce
petit truc
alors qu'est-ce que gaillac alors
qu'est-ce que gamoniac ne vous inquiétez
pas c'est pas un site qui vend des alpes
les super riches de quoi alors c'est
ainsi que des changes du jeu vidéo qui
nous permet en fait en version de
petites sommes chaque mois d'avoir accès
à un ou deux jeux donc vous prenez le
jeu une fois que vous ai joué c'est bien
beau mais après qu'est ce que vous en
foutez et bien le mettre au fond du
placard harel pour y est bien là au lieu
qui pourrissent au fond du placard vous
leur envoyez et vous entrez par d'autres
à la place aux nettement c'est un truc
qui me permettra d'économiser vraiment
beaucoup d'argent et je vous conseille
ça en tant qu'admin youtube heures
passées au moins voir un petit temps sur
une voie si ça vous intéresse de toute
manière le site est gratuit ça ne vous
coûte rien bon alors c'est ça le truc à
gagner sont en fait des cartes squeeze
donc avec mon petit logo de la peinture
et puis je la fin c'est beau voilà alors
là la plupart d'entre vous doivent se
dire what the fuck à quoi ça sert alors
comment ces cartes sont en fait des
autocollants nous on peut vous amuser en
maître en plus partout certains gros
aussi les collectionneurs et merde j'en
ai ras le cul la [ __ ] [ __ ]
heureusement que mes camarades sont là
ça me rend vraiment le moral
publicité mensongère ce petit le rouge
juste ici aussi été créé dans le but de
donner une petite utilité à la carte
une petit des tic tac artois la carte
fait tort je te défie je relève le défi
y a deux trois quarts pub papier c'est
aux as tu as gagné pour cette fois j'ai
de gros défis d'accord 1-2-3 quimper
folle à la chose chapiteau aujourd'hui
je découvre des ferries hockey ou alors
certains rappeurs d'entre vous coûtera
spécialisé pour les utiliser leurs clips
en mode
attends tu dis que ça sonne
antoine me situe
ton nom
avec toutes sortes de mort
alors recevoir votre carte cousy il
suffit de cliquer sur le lien qui est
juste dans la description et on n'a que
cinq mille à gagner donc dépêchez vous
vous rentrez votre mail vous validez
vous attendez bien que sa charge et vous
recevrez un mail de confirmation pour
dieu vous avez gagné votre petite carte
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas été assez
rapides et qui n'ont pas le temps d'en
avoir gagné lui ne vous inquiétez pas
j'ai des stocks ici et j'en free gagner
aux rencontres à poney ou à plein notre
hub inquiétez pas il y en a plein en
tout cas dépêchez vous de tenter votre
chance cliquez sur le lien dans la
description et on se retrouvait en
attendant une nouvelle vidéo et je
voulais sur la dernière touche à tout le
monde pis